hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
everything is the same nothing has
changed
nothing's changed nothing
no one nothing
especially no
[Music]
longer
this is janitor bleeds
i'm pretty sure most janitors would
bleed if you
cut them or something like that but i'm
assuming i'm not the one doing the
cutting
the daily local missing local only the
car found a local man has gone missing
he was last seen as he was exiting the
town bar a couple of days ago his car
was recently located on a forest road
miles away from any habitation
okay well this seems very familiar to
most horror games
car forest missing man local missing
local
local car and a local forest so far the
searches have been inconclusive
the police are desperate for any
information about the case the
disappeared man
the disappeared local man isn't the only
lone driver gone missing in the local
area
there have been multiple local reports
of local people disappearing along that
very same local forest local road
never to be seen again in the local
vicinity
oh my god
all right hey how's it going i am slow
i am sluggish my legs don't work
properly
ooh that's some rustling wind
i don't know why i always go the way
that's clearly blocked
i just feel like there's always secrets
um
okay little spooky not that spooky
kind of spooky amp up the spookage i
don't know what that means but just go
ahead and try
oh you did it you did the thing oh lexie
and you're good
lexie and you're real good you're so
good at your job
i should give you a raise that was
incredible
how have you started to do effects right
when i'm playing
before you even know weird
not gonna look into it too much okay
conveniently placed blockades of cars
again not gonna question it
hemos hemos arcade
hemos hemos hemos what kind of name is
hemos like hemoglobin
or hemo sapien you guys got any of those
hemos hemos
knows hi oh well that's convenient
love me don't eat me
okay hmm
okay hi
press control that is a weird thing to
graffiti on a board
i should do that oh my god we should
totally do that we should just start
graffiti
instructions for like keyboard controls
but out in real life so people get
confused
oh my god how bad would that mess with
someone's mind if they were just out in
the forest and it said
press shift to run
do it do that thing do the thing do that
thing do that thing
we're gonna do that then go out and do
the thing don't tell anybody about it
though
let people just find it just go do the
thing and let people find it
i am encouraging graffiti
it is up to your own discretion i am
waving all responsibility for this
go on your own way target
yeah i remember playing tort
fortune i remember playing torjin when i
was a kid
oh what a game towards a coin i have
that
apparently not okay
it's lovely very nostalgic you know in a
lot of ways it doesn't look any
different than what it normally would
look like
because it'd be just this dirty and just
as grimy
the cheese something something vengeance
all right okay man hey
all right oh
all right okay well this looks
like a one-way trip i'm assuming this is
fine
hi i got key
great mmm power
oh amp up the spookage again
if you could do that oh what about this
what about this
hey elixin can you amp up that spookage
really
really appreciative if you could
come on lexian i know you can do it come
on
lexie and amp up the spookage amp it up
[Music]
amp it up oh
hey do not
do not clue well i don't know what that
means insert two coins
i have to get coins i know where coins
is i saw the coins before
didn't let me grab them before but i saw
them
um blue door blue key probably okay
well this is interesting oddly in depth
i know where that other coin is i'm just
looking around for another one
might be well hidden or it might not be
or there might be more than three
maybe you know like oh got it okay i
know where the last one is
pucker [ __ ]
yeah pucker you know pucker yeah pucker
you know pucker
i needed to crouch what's the answer
bam e
insert three coin boom boom boom
nice okay level one oh
god boy i love being a janitor oh
i love janitorizing
okay so where does the bleeding part
come in
when's there gonna be bloodinating when
is bloodination gonna happen
okay
sure i'm glad that i took a break from
my car crash to come
oh
it's missing no is that a mewtwo is that
a mew
okay well good
i'm gonna not regret what i'm about to
do
at all oh good
hi hey all right i'll unleash the
darkness
bam i'm bleeding
oh no oh no
do not blow i have no idea what that
could mean hey
someone knocked over the trash can hi
alexian please tone down the spookage it
is too spooky
down hold it down what are you doing
you are evil oh
coin hmm
well the orchestra has uh showed up
sounds good
okay good
good i guess i go
turn the power back on
oh that's normal
hey what's going on in here we're having
a rave
you didn't invite me
[Laughter]
hello
[Music]
no work all right i'll hold ctrl
you got it you you got it holding ctrl
that would be very problematic to see
around normal vents in real life
okay i would like that sony papa who put
that there
who put this here
oh
that's probably fine probably nothing i
need to worry about
okay cool thanks thank you for that
that's great hey cool i appreciate that
really good stuff you're doing to me
hi where am i oh good more janitor
bleeding
more bloody janitor hey
hi oh boy
peekaboo peekaboo okay
do i need more coins i probably do to
get this going again
okay i got three
got four now i'm rich oh i got five hell
yeah
maybe i need to ah six goddamn i'm
loaded to the tits
okay here we go i'm gonna ignore all the
noises
because it's probably fine
is that a water cooler
what do i do with it there's an arcade
cabinet it might be the arcade cabin
i can't mop that
oh i see hi
great good good
good great
[Music]
okay oh
we're good hey we're good hey what's up
man we're good
all right we'll play again
yeah all right so um
is this way open now or no i still gotta
go get the key but i don't remember
seeing something to put it
[Music]
hi who's there all right
cool all right
i don't remember seeing uh not gonna
give me this
[Music]
yeah i don't remember there being any
kind of keyhole
okay what if i put it in the thing
no way
plus horse rings bore stam
oh [ __ ] hi oh that
yeah i bet i crouched there but hold on
one second
e e
e i okay i'm locked
i
can i open this no i don't know why i
would want to go in the bloody area
though
okay so this is where i come back when i
have a red key which i do not have
so that's good that's great good for
that and good for me
i love this
love this love this
great stuff great hey
hey look at that uh okay no all right
not
here for that but there hi
there was another um there was another
yellow door at some point ooh cash
register
perfect thank you yeah there was another
cash
uh yellow door probably around this
corner
oh that's not good is that not good how
good is that not
it's fine
okay well that's a blue door
is there a yellow door
high high closer closer
oh i'm not hiding well enough because i
can see him
oh no oh no
well that didn't work out too well i
couldn't seem to close the door
i think my problem might have been
standing right in the way where he would
have seen me
oh i'm here oh but i have the yellow key
okay i can just go ahead
well that was my stupidness but whatever
hi what's going on you in here buddy
i don't think i can hide oh i can hide
i know exactly oh yeah nothing like
toilet money
hmm okay so i go in here oh yeah here we
go here we go here we go
oh yeah oh yeah here we go oh yeah
you'll never see you'll never see me
you'll never see me
oh you'll never see me oh you're never
gonna see me
oh yeah that's right oh you got legs oh
you got leg are you the bleeding janitor
[Music]
[Applause]
it twerent nothing like it twerk
nothing which it twerked in case you
were wondering it
weren't nothing okay good was there
anything in here i actually needed to
get
uh probably not just a coin well that
was useless and pointless and why did i
do that
i don't know i don't know you know i had
an instinct that i was supposed to go
underneath
oh that was supposed to go underneath it
but you know my
i didn't trust my gamer instincts which
are incredibly honed they're incredibly
honed
okay so what i'm guessing is that these
arcades represent a representative of
the map of the
place that i'm in lexian remix those
words to make them make sense
so what i'm guessing is that these local
arcades are representative of the place
that i'm in
thank you okay
i don't think i can go down here can i
nope well
that's on something's gonna kill me when
i get up here
nope door open is the door open in real
life
could it be no it's not it's just going
to give me the blue key because it's
some kind of alternate reality
oh hi thank you blue key thank you
kurt chunkles hey oh is this a way out
oh it was the way out okay
cool that was awesome i really enjoyed
that the styling was good
you know the monster was nice and
distant for most of the demo
you know once i faced it obviously it
always removes a lot of the scariness of
the monster but
when it comes down to the atmosphere and
like the styling i had fun with that i
was really enjoying myself going there
so not bad i like that very good moving
on
all right so this one is called mr
jorkman in trouble
mr jorcmon mr mr jorkman was a famous
gastroenterologist
he is well known for the cure of his
four people who got disease with the
guts
he has healed more than 500 people some
of his patients say that he has a
magical cure
but now all his fame ended because he
has failed on a patient
and this resulted in the patient's
suicide before the suicide the patient
argued that mr
jorpman tried a new and untested cure
after these events mr jorkman could not
continue his job
he is now living in an old apartment
alone i
as a journalist wish to make an
interview about this with mr jerkman
and i wonder what happened to the
patient's guts
why would you who wonders that i'm
actually afraid to go there because
people say that the patient's ghost
haunts mr
jorp but i will take the risk because it
will be worth it
because i'm a journalist and this is
apparently what journalists do
hey mr jerkman hi
jorkey man hey what's going on jerkman
i'm coming in hello must not be home
i guess i'll give up
i guess i won't give up
oh that was quick but i expect him to be
behind the door and i wanted to surprise
him all right whatever you say buddy
whatever you say
mr jerkman you taking a bath mr jerkman
you're taking a [ __ ]
mr jerkman you jerking it you jerkman
who
met mr mr mr mr jorkman
but miss mister met mr jerkman
he doesn't seem like he can wake up he
seems dead
all right mr jerkman you gotta something
um
your wall art is weird
anyway i better come back tomorrow or
something let me just explore the rest
of your
house yeah people stack books like a
blockbuster used to stack vhs's
that's normal all right bye mr jerkman i
guess
sure
oh mr dorkman i'll answer that for you
don't worry i'm a journalist hey mr
yorkman residence
mr jerkman you have an ominous rumbling
calling for you
you might want to come answer this hey
wake up hey come on
wake up it's perfectly normal for me to
visit it
12 17 in the morning
[Music]
no i could not take an interview with
him
so i'm trying to that image was burned
into my brain
let me analyze it here okay all right i
saw a guy in a red shirt on his hands
and knees with
ass pointed towards mr jorkman's
sleeping body
there was a can of gasoline did he butt
chug some gasoline
and then laid it on fire
what a way to go was this a ghost oh my
god mr jerkman
mr jordan mr jordan i love that 10
10 out of 10 10 out of 10. 11 out of 11
20 out of 20. beautiful
good stuff great stuff the greatest
stuff actually
okay moving on this is called next door
if you don't know who
junji ito is you need to look up his
work if you remember the thing about the
hole in the wall and how this is my hole
you know and the dur that i referenced
in
ice with markiplier um that's the artist
that made these angus
oh come on i can't study with this noise
all the time
i should give the guy upstairs a piece
of my mind
okay i'm gonna give the guy upstairs a
piece of my mind then
i'm gonna give him a piece of my mind
yeah the comics are uh
very very good horror comics like lots
of different
ideas and
types of scares
i'm not really thirsty well okay
fair enough hi i'm gonna give you a
piece of my mind
you better watch yourself
hello hi
hello so sassy
what do you want could you please lower
the volume
you always have it unbearably loud
you call this loud yes it is you're
disturbing the peace
i bet you're the only one complaining
you're too uptight
if the neighbor says it's too loud i'll
think about it
watch me you wait right here nerd
hey neighbor hey neighbor
excuse me
are you home anybody there probably not
home
they seem to be away a lot away
you sure it's not just an empty room of
course they don't complain if nobody
lives there
no it isn't empty sometimes i hear the
door opening and closing
doesn't seem to be anyone around today
though
okay i guess our conversation is over
well go ask oh
hi hello
okay bye she was home
looked kinda freaky too that's the first
time i ever seen her
why all the black what's going on could
you argue somewhere else please
hey listen hey what the hell
hi excuse me can i ask you something
i'm from downstairs does the loud music
from that apartment bother you too
well a little but our rooms are
separated
you should ask is next door she just
left
and there isn't anyone else what do you
mean
i'm pretty sure more women are living
there a strange
bunch they all have a different figure
but they dress completely in black and
they never say
anything not even a hello very
unfriendly if you ask me
hmm if that's all dear i still have some
laundry to do
have a nice day thank you have a nice
day
that is weird and all it doesn't really
help me
with the noise issue better get back to
my room to try some more studying
i don't remember this one in particular
i've read a lot of junji cho's stuff but
i don't
i'm not familiar with this one maybe i'm
thirsty
not really thirsty i'm not all right
then
yep still loud hey the music stopped
what happened
after all that trouble he gave me oh
well i can finally do some studying
hmm
it's already dark i could really use a
drink
yeah okay yeah okay
yeah i got a good feeling about this
oh yeah i got a real good feeling
hi
i'm really thirsty
oh hi is that guy from upstairs
hello sneeze
excuse me hey what are you doing there
oh it's you don't sneak up on me like
that don't sneak up on me like that
what's gotten into you no one knows what
the hell i was referencing there were
you you guys are on jump scare friends
i'll put in the description lexi and
remind me to put it in the description
you want to see like the beginning of my
acting ability
oh so what oh man you can't just sneak
up on someone like that
it's really quality delivery anyway
you're as white as a sheep
can i ask you something sure those
ladies next door to me
what's up with them what do you mean it
doesn't make any sense
i don't know how many people live there
but they never make a single sound
with these thin walls
i should be able to hear them talking
around it's freaking me out
hi hi hello
ah hello hi how are you you're tall
you're tall you're very tall okay bye
that's normal who are they
what things are they doing next door
what are they doing that not a single
sound leaks through the walls
i'm going back to my room see you around
hey i'm not thirsty after all later nerd
hey
what's going on buddy i'll leave him be
okay sure yeah i'll just
go home then
the smart thing to do would be go home
and not check up on what that lady
[Music]
what was that sounded like it came from
upstairs
[Music]
hmm
hi oh that's a fun cat
now whose cat is this it has a cursed
face
you have a cursed face just like me
alexander make that cursed okay i guess
goodbye
later kitty with the messed up face god
what an insult
not an insult to say about someone's
face oh that's cursed
it's a cursed bug that's probably fine
okay hey what's up dude okay
hello
are you okay the door seems to be open
yeah i'll just walk in yeah i'm just
barging
yeah yeah that's weird
nobody's home hmm
they really don't make any sound that is
strange
hey there's a hole over there yeah
must have been the wind yeah okay yeah
justify it yeah justify that yeah i'll
peek in the hole
oh yeah i'll peek in the hole how did
this get here
looks made maybe that guy did it
the freaking pervert i don't want to i
don't want to do that
i would rather not i would rather not
i'm going to do it
oh boy
oh
maybe stop looking no why would you
why would you do this why would you do
this
oh no
[Music]
uh oh that's not good oh hey oh extendo
go go gadget arm
what is she those limbs why do they
extend and contract does
this mean all those women with different
figures
are exactly the same woman okay
yeah that's the weirdest part of this
i won't go out the door i'm not gonna go
where is she going
i wonder i wonder where
hi
did she leave no
no can i jump out the window
oh no oh oh oh
oh no oh no oh
no no no oh
no
and i escaped just in time did i did i
did i do that did i
as if nothing happened the woman
continued to reside
next door
[Music]
i'm moving away as fast as i can
as fast as my little leggies will take
me i'm moving away
[Music]
yeah i wouldn't really stick around to
pack up my stuff
oh that's pretty good i like that i
thought the ending was gonna be a bit
more bloody you know when i'm countered
by a
little robo spider woman kind of
terrifying probably deadly
although just did it just seem to be
like metal slats and all that but i like
that a lot
i like that a lot i like that very much
the style was good you know i always
love a good pixelated game
but uh the animations were fluid and it
was very fun
i don't like that i don't like that a
lot
[Music]
that is it for three scary games thank
you everybody so much for watching
remember
everything's always the same always
static
always unchanging
nothing really changes because nothing
ever really does
[Music]
you